we cannot allow criminal activities to
be left unpunished the number of
inquiries have been initiated arising
from the Panama papers data Panama
papers the biggest leak to date more
than eleven million files from an
offshore law firm were made public the
Finance Minister de Germany Ireland
Italy and the Netherlands faced
questions from any piece from the
parliaments inquiry committee set up to
investigate revelation from the leaks
to be quite frank for too long the
Netherlands has been part of this
problem in over the past few years we
have been part of a process taking
important steps to fight tax fraud tax
evasion tax avoidance and money
laundering around one trillion euros in
yearly tax revenue is lost to tax
evasion and fraud within the EU alone
money that could have been used to fund
education help and other public services
another part of the problem lawyers
bankers accountants and others involved
in setting up offshore schemes
jinsol media jocano lo-lo's determinant
a monopoly disposition is chemi final
izzati evader ellen post a so tiny
anokhin [ __ ] grand a conventional
obligated disclosure to intermarry i
bottom line is there's still not enough
transparency
yom-yom des hommes sessions possesses an
transparent circus Tiger sovereign in
the interior traffic corrected informed
on eminent Rastafarian
for the armed services and see owned by
gate by generating enforcers and first
shelf while the leaks have prompted some
changes many questions remain unanswered
the committee report points out that
what is ver so far may just be the tip
of the iceberg
[Music]